of August
the attendance list is going round so
all the Tendencies will be recorded we
have one apology from councilor Thomas
and councilor Lloyd has very kindly
agreed to substitute for her
um we just have the one item to consider
tonight which is the application for the
grants of a new premises license
under Section 17 of the licensing Act
2003. 106 and 108 Ashley Road hail
Altrincham
um so I'm councilor German I'm chairing
the licensing panel with me are other
Council of the councilor holding the
Council of lawyer to make up the
licensing panel
we have offices from legal licensing and
governance
um now we have the applicant here which
is uh Mr Cash keshavazi
that's yourself
and you're accompanied by Miguel Angel
de Benito is that yourself
now the representatives the ones I have
down to speak are if you could just
identify yourself Paulina Lewis
foreign Simpson
plus yourself and Paul Luton
okay thank you very much
right I'll re read you through the
procedure for the meeting and then and
then we'll we'll we'll we'll carry on
with the meeting so
first I'm going to ask the licensing
office to outline the application
under their representative to address
the subcommittee committee and call any
Witnesses
the applicant and each of their
Witnesses May then be questioned by
members of the subcommittee officers and
any other party making representation
party making representation who will be
referred to as the representators
and other Representatives will be given
the opportunity to address the
subcommittee and call any Witnesses
the representatives and and any of their
Witnesses May then be questioned by
members of the subcommittee
offices and any other party making
representation
now for the purposes of tonight we we
have representations from in
environmental health but I don't think
they're they're not represented tonight
we have a written representation and
then obviously from yourself yourselves
members of the public
so after this I'll request all parties
involved to summarize the
representatives will be given two
minutes to summarize followed by the
applicant it will also be given two
minutes to summarize
um we will then adjourn the meeting and
the subcommittee will consider their
decision and I will announce the
determination of the application and the
reasons for the determination
this will be confirmed in writing within
five days of the hearing so is everybody
clear about the procedure
before we get into the business
okay thank you
um
you're going to introduce it please
thank you
good evening everybody
um Okay so
La Bandera hail
application the licensing act 2003
provides the premises license is
required in respect of any premises
where it is intended to conduct one or
more of the four licensable activities
these being sale of alcohol supply of
alcohol
regulated entertainment and or the
provision of late night refreshments
the council in its role as the licensing
Authority has received an application
for the grants of a premises license
from La Bandera Hale Limited in respect
of premises to be known as La Bandera
Hale which is to be located at 106 to
108 Ashley Road alteringham Hale
The Authority has received
representations against the application
which means this matter must be brought
before the subcommittee for
consideration
in respect of the application the
applicants has agreed for permission to
conduct the following activities live
music and recorded music indoors sale of
alcohol on the premises Monday to Sunday
10 a.m to 2 A.M
the following amendments of the hours
has been agreed between the applicant
and greater Manchester police live music
and recorded music indoors and sale of
alcohol on the premises Sunday to
Thursday 10 till 2300
Friday and Saturday 10 till 23 30.
a copy of the application and plan is
attached to the report at appendix a
the applicant describes the premises as
a restaurant bar maximum of 150 covers
including Terrace alcohol to be served
wine spirits cocktails and beer
the application is in respect of the
ground and first floor
a copy of the previous license for the
embassy is attached as appendix C
the applicant has submitted an operating
schedule which contains measures to
illustrate how it proposes to promote
the four licensing objectives and these
include measures agreed with greater
Manchester police during the
consultation period
these would be conditions on the like
these would become conditions on the
license if granted and they are listed
in Section 3 of the report
the application was advertised for 28
days and during this consultation period
The Authority received a representation
from the environmental health Team on
grounds of public nuisance a copy of
that representation is attached to the
report at appendix e
however since the report has been
written and shared with all parties the
applicant has reached agreement with
Nazarene Ali environmental health
therefore the below conditions will be
added to the license if granted
conditions noise from music and
Associated sources including DJs and
Amplified voices must not be audible to
such an extent that it constitutes a
nuisance at any noise sensitive
properties
all external doors and windows shall be
kept closed when regulated entertainment
is being provided except in the event of
an emergency
that shall be placed at all exits from
the premises in a place where they can
be seen and easily read by the public or
members and their guests notices
requiring customers to leave the
premises and the area quietly
use of external areas associated with
this application should not be permitted
Beyond 2100 hours
additional conditions the applicant
shall submits for approval prior to the
commencement of use a noise management
plan
for the external areas
the noise management plan shall be
implemented at all times that these
areas are in use
and the final condition no Amplified
music sound speakers shall be permitted
to any external part of the site
The Authority received 40
representations against the application
from local residents 11 of these
representations have been withdrawn
following the amendment to ours agreed
with GMP greater Manchester police
this means that there are currently 29
representations outstanding which must
be considered at this evening's meeting
details of the representations from
local residents are attached to the
report as appendix f and for the
benefits of the committee the following
represent representation should be
discounted as they have been withdrawn
and the numbers are there too okay
in conclusion the subcommittee is
requested to determine an application
for a new premises license in respects
of La Bandera hail 106 to 108 Ashley
Road Hale alteringham having regard to
any representations received National
guidance its own licensing policy and
the requirement to promote the four
licensing objectives
the options available to the
subcommittee are
to Grant the application in full and on
the terms and conditions contained
within the application to include any
applicable mandatory conditions
to Grant the application but modified to
such an extent has considered
appropriate to satisfy any relevant
representations and promote the
licensing objectives or finally to
reject the application
and that concludes my briefing notes
thank you very much thank you so just to
conclude the the hours have been amended
now so a Live recorded music
on the sale of alcohol on the premises
Sunday to Thursday
except 10 o'clock till 2300 hours
priority to Saturday Friday and Saturday
10 o'clock to 23 30 hours
and the the opening times of the
premises are the same yes those are
those activities
sorry those conditions have been agreed
between the applicants and greater
Manchester police
okay thank you
um does anybody have any questions of
the lot questions for the licensing
officer before we move to the applicant
submission
yes just a piece of clarification we
mentioned
at the doors which is
regular specification in 2001 which was
the first time
foreign
[Music]
I don't I don't think they would apply
in this circumstance no that may be for
planning rather than the licensing
Authority
but what's been applied for is strictly
what we've outlined here
is
whatever they are
okay the second important clarification
was somebody mentioned terrorists
I understand you at the moment is that
there is no approval from the council
because
can I intervene we we had this
discussion
um last Wednesday
um this committee is a licensing
committee it is not a planning committee
and this use of planning must go before
the planning Authority which is
different from this committee appreciate
it it's a difficult difficult concept to
grasp because they're both both
different Departments of the local
Authority but this application has to be
looked at as it stands on its face uh in
accordance with the the licensing act
and not the planning regulations
but but it is not something that this
committee can consider other than that
you will have heard in the briefing that
the licensing officer read that the
provision of the use of the terrorist is
to end at 2100 hours that is something
that the committee can take into account
and can impose as a condition as has
been agreed but it can't deal with the
widerous user planning
okay yes you have a question
but you have a question for the
licensing officer we're not getting into
the substance of the thing with just for
clarification and this day
you were talking about doors
it's just exactly as I read it so if it
was just doors on the application then
it would all doors and windows and
windows whatever materials are made from
it will be everything yes
yeah it will be everything
okay
yes
sorry is this part of the
the substance of
following this in this process to
assessment
[Music]
and we believe
then we would say in 2001 there was an
assessment line in the end of the
committee of the noise
can I assist can can I assist you
um because I I will have to give advice
to the committee and it is this it's the
same as I said a moment ago this
committee must consider this application
as it stands today it cannot take into
account any application in relation to
any other license premises or this
license premises many years ago which is
what you're asking it to do it cannot do
that
we wanted to explain
restrictions that are weren't on this
property for 20 years
to prevented any noise pollution or any
noise uses to any of the residents this
is in a residential area so what we
wanted to explain that's a
representation that you can make later
it's not a question now
there will be one of the conditions is
that a noise management plan has to be
submitted
to the satisfaction of the environmental
health officers so all that will will be
gone into and as long as they're happy
there are other conditions
saying that noise can't be heard or
vibration spelled at noise sensitive
property so there are conditions
covering that
anything relating to the planning and it
may well be that 2001 has now been
superseded by another planning
application but you need to contact the
planning department and they would need
to get their enforcement offices to look
at the necessary detail on that that's
not something we can do
foreign
it doesn't come under our remit it's
it's something for the for the planning
in terms of the outside area
right well I suggest you chase it up but
that's not a matter that we can consider
you need to chase it up with the
planning department
sorry about that
yes
well take take it higher then take it to
the chief exec or something but it's not
something we can deal with at this you
know it's not in our remix
if you're waiting for a sound
a noise assessment noise management it's
in the conditions at the office of Red
Owl yes
um
yeah
additional conditions 22.
but it's subject to that being approved
so if it's not approved to to the
environmental health officer's
satisfaction then it doesn't get
approved basically
that's the condition
well we can make a decision here but it
is subject to that condition being
satisfied like all the conditions have
been satisfied
they wouldn't be able to start the
operation without that being done
if I can assist a noise management plan
is a standard requirement or many
licenses where noise is an issue
if there is a complaint about noise it
then falls on environmental health the
people that you've heard of nazreen
Ali's Department to investigate that
which they will do if it is found that
the premises are acting in breach of
their noise management plan or that they
are causing a statutory noise nuisance
then the the environmental health
department has various options they can
take in relation to it one of them
involves bringing them back before this
committee by way of review another
involves note proceedings under the
noise abatement tax so it is a standard
condition that has been put on and it
does have sanctions if it is not
complied with
okay can can we move on
um
you have a question
um can I just ask the applicant if
they'd like to speak to their
application just tell us about what the
what's proposed and how it's going to
run thank you
good evening
thank you all for being here
my name is Yasin and um
as you know
um trying to open a restaurant in the
area of hail
I'll tell you a little bit about my past
and why I want to open inhale so
um I've got a restaurant called La
Bandera in Manchester City Center we've
been operating for over eight years now
and for the last
um eight years that we've been open we
never had any issues with the licensing
whatsoever we have a very
um good at that and I think our license
is one of the best ones in terms of
um what we allowed to do and what we
actually do
um
ever since I
went to hail for the first time I fell
in love with it and I thought
um
it would be the perfect place for the
expansion of our brand LA Bandera which
is a Spanish slash Canarian restaurant
and I want to make an emphasis of the
word restaurant we are not a nightclub
or a bar and the ward bar is there
because we serve alcohol therefore it
needs to be there but we are not we
don't have a dancing area we don't
provide
um
like late nights not even in the
restaurant in city center
and the restaurant was open in 2014 by
my brother my sister myself it has
always been a family-run restaurant
and now
I my family has grown my brother's got
kids and I've got kids as well I've got
two little I've got twins two little
three two and a half years old
um believe me the last thing I want to
do is to spend uh my late nights in the
restaurant working when I have family to
go home too and the only reason we'd
apply for the uh this license at two
o'clock it was because we all we did
maybe it was a mistake but what we did
basically we took the same
a license we have at the restaurant in
the city center will copy it and we
submitted it to the Trafford Council
now as as soon as we received the first
um comments or representations we agreed
straight away with all the conditions
that were were given to us because it
doesn't affect our
um our concept it doesn't affect what
we're planning to do and obviously we
want to get on well with all our
neighbors as we do everywhere we go we
have one of obviously Lavender is our
brand but we also have all the brands
one of them already open in hail which
is coffee bee hail and that has been
trading now for a little while and we
have a license as well that is never we
never had issues we have a good
understanding of the neighbors the
community and we want the first thing we
would like for all the neighbors is To
Be Our Guests our customers to feel free
to come and enjoy our food we are very
proud of what we do and we
um we we focus on the food
given the data from the restaurant in
the city center even though in the city
center you wouldn't expect that 75
percent of our revenue is food 25 is
possibly the wines that go with the food
we don't have many people that come
drinking or
troublemakers our service our
um concept
um and our history and the way we we
treat people it's you know is is not
usually very welcoming to the people who
want to go out have a couple of drinks
and make a mess uh be troublemakers and
all that I mean I understand everybody's
concern
and I think
um
the wrong
image of us has been has gone out
because of the type of licenses we were
applying for now since we received this
um
representations we have worked closely
with all the authorities involved and
the represent the representations in
order to achieve an understanding but
most importantly in order to
um communicate to everyone what our
intentions are
I do understand there is a residential
area
but it's also a Street full of other
restaurants we wouldn't be the only one
there
uh in fact two doors next door there is
a pub that opens until half 12 one
o'clock on the weekends uh we won't be
doing that
as as the lady here just said with the
new opening times but we're not a pub
either we wouldn't have a drinking area
or a dancing area it's all restaurant so
if you would like to come to the
restaurant and have a drink we'll
possibly ask you to sit down in our
tables and do it there and then because
it won't be a designated area for
drinking only or dancing whatsoever
um yeah and again the other concerns I'm
I'm not I think we're not here to
discuss that and it could be taken to
because I wasn't aware of them concerns
um I can prepare for what was discussed
in the enemies but I wasn't aware of any
any other concerns that you just pointed
out
but of course we are happy more than
happy to work with all our neighbors and
um I think
I think the unit itself is a beautiful
place for us to expand I think once you
see what we do you will be proud of
having us as your neighbor restaurant
and if you could have the option of
choosing
um in the future who would like to have
as the the restaurant Terrace downstairs
I am 100 sure 100 sure and I can
guarantee that
who would be the chosen one because when
that's
that's how we work We Are Family We Are
Family running the restaurant and we
also have families we weren't there to
go to a community and start causing
problems and issues to anyone I think
that's that's
the message that he was sent wrong at
the beginning maybe because of the hours
of the licensing maybe because it was
some I don't know boarding out there but
yeah I welcome you all to come to my
restaurant we do have a two o'clock
license in the city center
you will never see any of my managers
leaving the place after 12 o'clock
not even weekends because people come
dine and go don't come they don't come
for drinks and that's the same concept
we just thought it was easier to do it
that way because
it could have saved a lot of paperwork
and write him down but apparently it
didn't so that's why we as soon as we
found out it was some concerns
no hesitation we took it back we said
okay so what was the restaurant doing
before it was here do the same send
Sunday to Thursday until 11 and Fridays
and Saturday until half 11 and that's
exactly the same license that the
previous restaurant had I believe and in
fact my solicitor said well actually we
can go with this with the license in the
two doors down the road has which you
have to have on one o'clock the pop I
said no it's okay we're not the pub just
keep it as the previous restaurant so we
want to send a message that we are only
a restaurant
I'm a very good one by the way good
thank you good so what you're saying is
you're just operating as a restaurant
you're not operating as a public Bar no
no so you can't just go in and order a
drink at the bar
just to be clear so we won't be we
wouldn't be having sitting at the bar no
right so it's table service only yeah
the only
um just to be specific the only reason
we could have somebody at the bar is
because they came early for a table and
they're waiting at the buff of the table
for the reservation if they reserve the
table at eight o'clock and they hype
half a seven
if it's raining especially wouldn't ask
him to wait at the street yeah cool I
think it's only common sense to allow
them to have a drink at the bar until
the red the table is ready so what was
what's the purpose of of the music
license because I believe after 11
o'clock it has to be considered as
um live music
yeah well right I mean we don't need a
license before 11. exactly that's the
main reason is that we don't have yes
every now and then every now and then on
a Sunday with the
in the afternoon
um special locations
um I think in the last year in the last
eight years I can't count maybe 10 times
that we've had live music but it's not
like
is like the same level as the I mean if
you join our Instagram you will see what
kind of music it is is the same level as
the background music but it's just a
lady singing
in the afternoon so you only really need
it for two days a week for that half an
hour between yeah I want to restrict it
because we also have had birthday
parties that I
um
we have allowed in the past in our
restaurant that they uh like the last
time it was a lady that was their 65th
birthday and she wanted her son-in-law
to be the singer at the at the
restaurant from 12 to 3 o'clock and it
was a Tuesday so I'll tell you you're
not gonna have more than 500 people
there are you sorry you're not going to
have more than 500 people because that's
what the license restricts you don't
need a license if there's less than 500
oh no no I think I think I think I read
150 people maximum yeah
I mean that's what the and these 150
people because that's exact covers that
we have sitting down okay
um just looking at the plans here they
don't on page 33 of the report they
don't give a lot of detail
about uh what What's where they don't
even take the two floor plans so there's
two floors uh if you alarm if you want
me to explain yeah so there's two floors
the first floor is the restaurant
seating area and on the right side there
is a bar
saving bar downstairs is mainly the
toilets the kitchen storage and there is
a little private room as well
which mainly will be used for the stuff
sorry the one on the right is the ground
floor is it
um
[Music]
right so yeah where he says kitchen is
the ground floor yeah sorry basement
basement
okay so it's basement on well ground
sorry yeah yeah okay
so the kitchen and the bar is
on the ground floor no the kitchen is on
the ground floor
no kitchen is in the basement bar is on
okay
I'll just ask any of my colleagues have
any uh questions this day
not for me yet oh sorry yes come on
where in the city center is your
Restaurant Richfield just sorry just off
Dean's gate
um
there is two Sainsbury's on Dean's guide
the one let's say there is one closer to
Hilton among closer to the cathedral so
the one on the cathedral in front of it
there is uh there is a new hotel called
your hotel now
there is a building that has Dunkin
Donuts a post office so we're in that
same building on the back side on that
building
he used to be a club downstairs called
South
we're above South
no no no don't
you know the restaurant Lavinia
just behind them are they our neighbors
yeah
yeah the building next door is
residential
above the art gallery is always
residential we have two alcoholics
residents up there we never had any
issues in fact they are our regulars
that's what we always hope for
okay can I just ask you about on the
outside area is going to be monitored
because obviously there's no outside
sitting up to nine pm
and also at closing time because you're
going to put notices up which don't in
themselves stop people
just you know just in case there's so
will you be moving people on if they
congregate well
as we don't have a space for drinking
only we do have
um a system for bookings and
reservations so we will allow the rest
the last reservation for the Terrace to
be at seven o'clock
and therefore they have two hours and
the early access to the Terrace is
through the restaurant we'll be closing
the door at nine o'clock
and I welcome everybody back in
obviously I'm not going to leave them
outside
right and when and when the after
closing time how are you
you know I'm not suggesting
unnecessarily happen but I mean
occasionally could happen that people
congregate
with parties and so on how are you going
to monitor that
for the noise when they live in the
premises yeah so it was suggested that
we put signs and
um
um make sure we explain everybody
and
that they are responsible for yeah the
manager on duty will be responsible yeah
we will provide means as well
okay
um I'll just ask the residents if they
have any questions I'm sure they do
would you like to ask the applicant
yes please
I think if it's a part of the restaurant
will be
could be used for both for people
um having food
or if they want to if they're inside I
want to go for a cigarette they can
possibly either use the front or the
back door
sorry do you would like to repeat
so it could be used potentially for both
dining and if they diners inside want to
have a cigarette break they can go from
the front door or the back door
in the back until nine o'clock after
nine o'clock nobody will be allowed
until nine o'clock
until 9 pm 9 pm the doors will be closed
nobody's allowed out from the back door
anyway
sorry
can we have stories
oh sorry
elected to speak sorry cool yes would
you like carry on with your question or
do you have another
yeah I mean if the weather permits yeah
weather permitting yeah I mean who
wouldn't like to have a nice meal if
it's a nice day out there yeah
in the UK
yeah exactly it won't be that many
months a year that we will be used we
don't count I mean is the revenue just
to clear the revenue of the Terrace is
not considered in our forecast because
obviously this summer is proving me
right we can't really rely on a
terrorists that it won't be used more
than a week or two weeks per year
okay yes I'm glad it's not in your
business plan because we'll be
challenging any use of the service
whatsoever
but I can't tell you why because it's
not under the licensing that's not a
question and it's not really an
appropriate line to go down on this
committee and I would advise the
committee to disregard that because it
it's not a it's not a fair way of
proceeding I'm afraid
all right
first of all can I just show you a
sketch of the area please I'm familiar
with the area but I'd be happy to have a
look
and where the location is in yellow
right
um
sorry do you understand what you're
applying for here this is in a
residential area do you agree I agree
that we won't be the only restaurant in
that area as well yes
there is the railway club which quite
frankly this is on this side of the
Railway yeah further down there is
locality this is at the end of The
Village his app is expressed on what the
one in Orange
[Music]
they're completely surrounded by the
residential sorry is it Mr Luton
speaking on on the inside I've forgotten
your name
Mr Simpson you've made a point about the
hail Tavern uh there are those of us who
are here on Wednesday who know that
those premises were only granted a
license on Wednesday
are you saying those premises have
opened and have caused a nuisance to
date
I could imagine the purpose of this
committee is to use very very foresight
yes but the point you made
the point you made was the the premises
in Orange have caused no nuisance and
you singled out the hail Tavern and the
railway Pub
the ones in green obviously there's the
railway Pub and there is the hail Tavern
which will okay the hell Talent is not
in operation yet but it's entirely
foreseeable but before 9 pm it will
cause noise nuisance to the houses in
Ashley Road and Spring Road
and the point I'm trying to try to
stretch with regard to the plan is that
this is the very last
commercial premises at the end of The
Village so all the way to the right and
all the way at the back is residential
property and you've said you don't wish
to upset the residents of course not I
do believe there was a restaurant there
before
[Music]
the doors at the rear and there was no
Terrace okay but the terrorist situation
I think it was agreed that is not no
what I'm saying to you is would you
would you be so we would have I would
personally no objection whatsoever if
you confirm to this committee now that
you will open that restaurant because
you've said the Terrace is not part of
your business plan yeah I said it's not
part of our forecast
so if you will if you will restrict your
application so that you do not
allow any access to customers to the
terrorists and the rear of the property
and you do not open the doors and allow
all the noise of the restaurants into
our properties on Spring Road and Ashley
Road and all the residents because you
will ruin our lives if you will agree
that here and now we will happily say to
you that that is an absolutely third
thing to do because for 20 years there
was a restriction that the doors
couldn't be opened if I'm telling you
that that's the truth I promise you no
windows and no doors could be opened and
it caused no noise nuisance to us at all
so if you will agree now to say you will
not use the terrorists allow access to
customers because apparently it's not
going to make you any more money you've
told us that it's not quality business
plan if you will agree to that we don't
have a problem I'm really would love you
to be very successful with business
within the building
so just simply you're saying the
previous restaurant did not use the
Terrace
they then constructed a Terrace
we objected to it we wrote to planning
oh and well I'm sorry I've used that
phrase again we objected to it asked
them not to build it but they didn't
engage the group of Builders from Spain
who came over and they built it they
built in a tie with
as far as we know for a fact can I just
interrupt you're getting into planning
issues again can we just concentrate on
the licensing applications
okay this Terrace I don't believe is
being built with any building
we've explained planning is not
something this committee can take into
account you you've asked a question
you've asked the question of the you've
asked the question of the applicant
would he would he agree not to use the
terrorists it's probably fair to allow
him an opportunity to answer these
that's not something we have considered
yet if this question was raised before I
could have consulted and raised it first
of all with the landlord and asking to
reduce the the the price of their rent
because it's a space that we wouldn't be
used but as is charged me for it it was
not considered and obviously the the the
days that it was shown to us the uh the
the
the premises it was shown by the Terrace
we have been in the in the restaurant
before and we know it was used we have
been sitting there and having food there
so I think it would be unfair to agree
to anything that he wasn't related or
mentioned before uh as now or today and
I'm sure we can um
come to an agreement and I'd be happy to
to listen to you know different
suggestions but throwing this at me
today now here without any previous
warning I don't think it would be fair
for me to give you a straight answer
um could I could I ask also you said
there's 150 covers yeah does that
include the Terrace
yes
the applicant said there was 150 covers
within the building
you're going back to 2001 that's not the
application before I would like to
answer that anyway it's just the our
layout and design for how the sitting
area is going to be that
[Music]
like because I think you're alone for
effectively 200 covers how many covers
are there in on the tariffs
um about 15 to 20 15.
now with the layout
we will not be using
um
we will not be using the layer the
current layout it's in the operating
schedule no more than 150 customers it's
they're imposing that condition on
themselves
so what's the question sir
you're the 150 I asked the question was
it inside or did it include outside
that's all together
[Music]
it's 6.7 meters
by 5.4 there are 32 chairs outside there
is bench seating all the way along do
you seriously think
ing anything
I think the licensing is is limited to
150 people all together so if you think
it would be more people out there but
the some the total sum is not more than
150 we think I still
um
go with the licensing however I I want
to repeat
um the layout that the previous
restaurant had will have nothing to do
with our layout our layout it's um
in a way a little bit more
comfortable so we allow more space per
customer therefore less covers per
square meter
so yeah and yes
um
I would I would like to discuss this
further with you guys if you like me to
but as I said I don't think it was fair
for you to bring this when I had no idea
about this issue
[Music]
of the doors into the kitchen or you're
on the toilet downstairs are you aware
about it
yes I don't know if you have seen the
landlord doing some work lately there
everything has been changed
if I can intervene the plans that are
submitted with the application doesn't
include The Terraces a licensed area at
the moment
so that will require a various ninjut
course
sorry you're saying that the plans
the plans that have been submitted only
include the internal areas of the
premise nothing external at all that is
what I said thank you
well I think there was a some
misunderstanding but it we we can only
license what's in front of us which is
the internal area
now if the applicant want wishes to we'd
have to submit a variation application
at some point which we then have to
consider
but I think we'd want to see this up and
running really
we do apologize
so on that basis Mr Mr Simpson you said
you didn't you you wouldn't object if
the terrorist is not included is that
the view of you all
yes
is that what it means well to be a
licensed area it has to be licensed for
various things one of which is the sale
of alcohol yes
so is that the view of you all then that
means
well you don't have to be you don't you
don't have to be unlicensed premises
areas to stand and smoke
because that is not a licenseable
activity
but what you cut what you could well
tell alcohol on the Terrace
part of my object and when I was going
to give a presentation was the problem
that the rear doors opened this is an
elevated restaurant
in the in the in the downstairs kitchen
and store rooms the restaurant you walk
up steps into it you walk down seven
steps to the Terrace The Terrace has had
an elevator of hunting relation to the
surrounding area
so
the restaurant it has an elevated height
if the taxes access to the terrorist for
any purpose
then the doors have to be opened and
what that means please look at the plan
and you will see the noise from the 150
people
in a restaurant that will be talking
laughing potentially singing Happy
Birthday
um sounded plates bottles all live music
all of that noise will come straight out
into the rear Gardens on Spring Road and
then be projected to Ashley Road all of
this residential area
so the opening of The Doors is the issue
and I I know I I cannot I can only tell
you what's happened for 20 years prior
to the last
lessees constructing but if you're then
turning if you're maintaining your
representations then we'll come to you
later
okay does that finish the questions to
the applicant but could you you'll have
a chance to make your representation you
have one more yeah that's fine yes you
said
please Harris anyway
we're now undecided whether you're
actually going to use the tariffs but if
somebody has gone there as a group
you've got 10 15 people though in a big
party it comes to 9 p.m how do you get
rid of them
[Music]
well
it wouldn't be our first time trying to
achieve something with our customers we
have our own ways and it's not like it's
the first restaurant we open we know
exactly how to they will be informed
before they exited to the terrorists
that the rest of the terrorists will
close on nine and a nine o'clock we will
have the waiters picking up everything
from the Terrace and asking them to come
back inside
[Music]
and go home
at nine o'clock the reservation is
finished
[Music]
I've not been in the restaurant and
being told I have to leave straight away
well you wouldn't you wouldn't you
wouldn't you wouldn't Reserve at nine
o'clock our last the last reservation
will allow you to have a full meal and
we allow about
105 minutes for tables of two and 120
Minutes Or tables or four or more so
that's two hours of last reservation for
four people outside would be at seven
o'clock they have two hours to finish
their meal at nine o'clock as it will
stay on the email they will have to
evacuate the table now if at nine
o'clock they wanna carry on drinking or
or eating if we have the possibility of
making them a new reservation on nine
o'clock inside the hood but if it's a no
then that's a problem I face every
Saturday in my restaurant because we are
very
presently as you can
you can't do that
the we're only we can only license the
inside areas the basement and the on the
first floor sorry the ground floor
that so uh that currently as it stands
you can't use the outside area for any
licensable activity
yeah but I think the concern about the
providing well they may be concerned
about people smoking I mean they'd have
to go out and open the door to smoke
I think the key contention is whether
the doors and windows have to be closed
it does say during during entertainment
I mean
you know if there's no music playing
and it's a hot day you got you know you
can't be expected to necessarily you
know you'd have to perhaps have a window
open to ventilate
is that I understand it is it's not
while it's dining and drinking it's well
there's there's music
okay so that
all the windows and doors have been
closed until 2021 and there's very large
air conditioning units I'm not on this
property
so it isn't it doesn't come too hot but
particularly for valve the opening of
the windows is terrible for her property
she lives next door that very small
section you see right next door to it
and she has to pull up with terrible
noise nuisance when the doors are open
on the on the sky yeah I think they've
established that they can't open the
doors and windows at any time during the
licensable activities
so that includes drinking
no just perspectives
[Music]
right that's during the regular
entertainment
you see when the when the music
you know is is on that's how it stands
but
there are there are conditions saying
that
you know it shouldn't be well noise
sensitive properties the music shouldn't
be shouldn't be heard or the vibrations
felt
so that that should cover it
okay
I mean really if if there's any problems
I think you know really you'd have to
contact the licensee in the first
instance and then if the problems
persisted provided that they Grant the
application that is then you would have
to contact the licensing who'd up to
look into it further
so ultimately they could amend or or
even revoke the license if it was a
problem
[Music]
your questions
I think so fun for me yeah right well
it's now a chance for you to make a
representation so would one of you
it's raining would you like to
um
okay I'm sorry I I live with my wife
with two two daughters number 18 Spring
Road and I have showing it on the planet
uh just directly behind the property
which is the subject of the application
and I wish to object to what it appears
to be an extent of what we thought was
an extension to the license for the
Youth selling of alcohol on the tariffs
and that was my main objection
and I'm not too sure that that is the
objection now
okay so I do apologize
the other aspect which is selling of
alcohol and playing with live music
until 11 30 P.M
um
if this application is granted I would
ask that you can run specific road
restrictions if that is possible and I
will mention them to you at the
conclusion
um so that as best as possible to limit
the noise nuisance the first thing I've
made the points already this is in a
residential area you've seen the plan
it's surrounded by residential property
um
if you look at the left hand side by the
way it's it's eight residential large
residential flats and particularly poor
values between two properties which will
make noise
um the other aspect to consider about
this property is its size it's look at
it in comparison to the other commercial
premises in that row which I I try to do
your Extensions by the coloring of
colorings yeah
except for the one which is green which
is the hail towel and I put HT on it but
it projects far in excess of any of
those other properties to the rear
boundary but there's been a Terrace
built which takes it 100 to the rear
boundary the whole footprint of the
property has been constructed and
constructed upon
um we've we've established about the
number of covers 150 people apparently
um the issue we have is it was about the
use of the terrorist still it seems you
haven't got planning permission or
you're not applying I should say you're
not playing a license for selling them
out on the Terrace we would not want
anybody on the Terrace and we do not
want anybody to have access to that
Terrace area and open the doors at the
rear and the reason for that is this
restaurants without an elevated level
and the noise will be projected there
will be no obstruction whatsoever no
walls nothing to retain the sound of
noise of 150 people within that premises
it will be projected over the walls and
into the properties like in Spring Road
and out towards all Residential
Properties on Ashley Road
um
I can say to you I think with I don't
know if I'm stepping onto clinic and I
hope I'm not and all I will say is this
that from 2001 to 2022
before the building the Terrace this
property caused no new noise nuisance
whatsoever nothing and we've lived there
and enjoyed our Gardens and rear
bedrooms and rear rooms in the back at
their
rear of our properties and the reason
for that is if you put a restriction on
the on the license that they cannot open
the rear doors at all saving cases of
emergency
if you maintain in your restrictions
that they have to maintain the use of
acoustic insulation including acoustic
glazing
if you also put a condition and
restrictions that all windows and
skylights be non-opening safe in case of
emergency then I guarantee you you will
never have a complaint from any of us
because the noise will be wholly
contained within that property and it
will not cause any noise Nations at all
to any of the local residents
um my very brief point and I don't want
to be repetitive because I know a member
of the committee was here on last
Thursday was about other properties and
I'll be very brief on this a license has
been granted for Hail Tavern which is
just one property down and that is to
serve alcohol until 12 p.m on alcohol on
a Terrace until 9 pm and that is to be a
sports bar we've climbed out all there
is no restriction on the opening of
doors and windows so until 9 pm there
will be the noise of potentially I don't
know the numbers 150 people it's not
like a restaurant these will be people
standing up watching televisions having
a drink
um let's just assume 100 to 150 people
we have the railway club with a beer
garden at the back but it's only a very
small beer garden but there's
potentially about 50 people there and
you wonder is that going to make any
difference well the truth of it is we if
you look where we are in Spring Road 18
Spring Road we can't leave our rear
windows open to sleep on Fridays and
Saturdays if the if the the railway Pub
has got a lot of people in the garden
because of the noise
it travels that far to us and that is
open well that's the problem with the
railway Pub then the railway Pub yeah it
always comes out from the gardens well
really you ought to take that up with
the railway Pub or with licensing
separately I mean this is an operation
that isn't isn't in operation yet we're
discussing tonight so I know you're
trying to paint a picture
I was trying to get the idea of of
putting yourself in a degree foresight
if a particular license is granted and
it allows the app it allows the rear
doors to open
what we will be faced with sitting in
our Gardens at 8pm will be 200 150
people plus staff plus the noise of a
restaurant
from this applicant's property we will
have the noise of the hail town with
cheering and whatever of 100 150 people
and we will have the noise from the
railway of say 50 people we're talking
about
350 people making noise and I would
suggest to you under no circumstances
could we foresee or we would hope that
you will be able to foresee that we
would have a right to quiet enjoyment of
our Gardens and any of the rooms at the
rear of our properties
um
I the final Point Elevate on it is just
a very small point this is a
conservation area and I don't know
whether that's irrelevant question to
take into account but I would imagine a
conservation means conserving the
character of an area and the nature of
an area this is a suburb a beautiful
suburb of a wonderful Borough
and we love living there and we are
extremely lucky to live there and we are
all law-abiding citizens
but the fact is our enjoyment of living
there will be completely taken away and
the nature of this area will be ruined
forever if too many of these licenses
are allowed because a whole
30 40 properties there will be people
who will not be able to enjoy quiet
enjoyment of their Gardens or the or
their rooms at the rear of their
properties so I would ask that I've just
re-stressed if you you must Grant a
license we totally accept you must Grant
a license please put a restriction on
that the rear doors are not to be open
to customers to the rear area
except in the case of emergency
but the property continue to be fitted
with acoustic insulation and obscured
insulation because it is raised and
looks into our garden
and that all the windows and skylights
be non-opening Acceptance in cases of
emergency and I just very well I won't
even say it it doesn't matter I'm very
very grateful to you listening to my
suggestions I really appreciate it thank
you very much
okay so it's it's just the rear doors
and skylights at the back
of this
had restrictions they've taken up the
like the acoustic glass it's gone it's
all clear gas glass it was supposed to
be obscured glazing and acoustic glazing
it's all been removed it's clear so I'm
I'm just I'm referencing that to please
accident yet that is not taken away
right well we still are obviously
awaiting the noise management plan from
the applicant I just wanted to does the
applicant have any comments about
so on this plan that you provided us and
my understanding is the the um the the
ones in Orange are shops and restaurants
such as pigs Express
okay so that's the Pizza Express
[Music]
that wasn't my question just
that's a business Express restaurant
the railway Pub
and then the hail Tavern
and they all have licenses
[Music]
okay the health Urban
just so you know it was the first place
I looked at when I was looking at the
place for and the Terrace is quite
massive
it's a massive restaurant it really is
there's a three-floor restaurant with
so yeah I remember the the Terrace being
if you yeah I mean at the moment is not
been looked after but if you take all
the bad grass and all the other ways at
least three times the size of our
Terrace
yeah yeah
and they can use it
okay
so they can use the the one that is with
the tiles you mean
okay and there is a pub in the in the
same place
right so these restaurants and pubs they
have licenses licenses and this is a
sports bar this is a pub and Pizza
Express
and they do have a license to pop in the
latest one
um
1 30 A.M
so my question really would be um
wouldn't be just unfair to
because if you look at the space between
the houses yeah you're looking at your
own house but there is other houses and
then the noise if he's there it would be
for everybody
I think it would be just unfair to to
you know pick on me the new kid who
wants to come on
same restrictions
Tavern as we're asking for your work but
that was but that was important issue
was dealt with last week that was that
was approved already yeah it
same restrictions that uh to be put on
this applicant as the hail Tavern uh
what would what what the committee would
have to do would be allowed this
gentleman to trade until midnight every
night Monday through Sunday through
Thursday and uh to one o'clock on the
morning on on Saturdays and Sundays so I
don't think
from what you're telling us that's what
you want on this application what I'm
what I'm saying
is that the restrictions to do with
doors and windows etc etc
um in our understanding we origin when
we're both both premises were first
opened their restrictions were put on
them both and they've been there the
whole time they only the only the issue
with uh with the hail Tavern is exactly
the same as we have with yours it's the
prevention of noise coming from the rear
of the building so we would be talking
to the planning committee or whatever
um to ensure that the
constraints that they put in at the very
beginning in 2001 are still applicable
and if that is the case that would mean
that you will not be able to use the
Terrace and the what we've described in
terms of doors and windows Etc would be
in place
and we would expect that from the Head
Tavern as well
you'll have to take up with the planning
as we we've covered already
yeah I'm just a bit confused my question
was so the health department has been
given a license into 12 o'clock until
one o'clock
no it's a matter of public record it has
on on
um
nine o'clock outside oh no the
restaurant itself
the premises itself has a one o'clock
license twenty three hundred hours on uh
Monday oh sorry Sunday through to
Thursday and um 23 59 on Fridays and 12
o'clock yes
but we're not we're not we're not
concerned with that application no no no
just
fine people were talking about the
concerns about my application being
earlier than them than the hell happened
and the health haven't been approved
it's just
um
would you be happy for what their What
the residents are asking that the the
doors and the windows at the back are
closed
which is what what they're asking is
part of the be asking me to copy the
same as hell tab in the windows on the
doors to close but to open until 12 then
instead of half eleven no no no I don't
know what I've not studied the RPO I was
on holiday last week so I wasn't
involved with the meeting as you
probably know but um so basically my
license will be more restricted
it goes back further than hail taverns
will be
that was the condition that was amazed
in relation to the hail Tavern the the
condition about keeping the doors and
windows shut was imposed from nine
o'clock in the evening yeah it's
obviously patently necessary that if
somebody is going to use a Terrace for
whatever reason that they will have to
open the door to get onto the Terrace it
doesn't mean to say the door has to be
propped open and it might be that that
is a reasonable compromise for you that
the door to the Terrace will not be open
unless somebody is going through it
would that satisfy your requirements
right
is there anything that would satisfy
your requirements that this cons
committee can consider given that it
can't consider imposing a planning
restriction on acoustic the use of
acoustic glass or Paddock
I'm afraid about my answer has to be no
there is no only one we can say because
these issues belong to the planning
Authority not to use well they can't be
considered by this committee so we can
we can draw a line under that because we
have to the acousticone definitely if we
can't you can't find it that's
absolutely fair I understand that but if
you can't restrict access to customers
to the rear tariffs and garden they were
with us to that description and that all
windows are skylarked to be non-opening
except in case of emergency yeah we as
we've already established we can only
um we can only license the internal area
at this stage now are you asking that
the rear doors be closed or at least
from a certain time
[Music]
150 people comes into our Gardens at an
elevated height
that's my submission and I don't know
how that how that can ever be considered
don't forget that you're you're open
throughout the daytime as well
you're open throughout the daytime as
well the whole of the afternoon it might
be a question of intensity at any
particular time I mean obviously as
things get made so noise Rises and I
think they have to be reasonable about
this about what is a reasonable time for
these licensable activities to be to
take place I think I think it's
reasonable that if the terrorist is not
being used
then it's quite reasonable for all the
doors and windows to be shut
and we know that this isn't part of your
business plan anyway you're happy to
make the business successful within the
building yeah I think we we're gonna
have to move on WE we've discussed
everything we know I think we know the
relative position so we we're going to
have to make a decision on that
so
no I think I think Graham's covered it
finally for me do you want to I've got
some other points that I'd like to raise
I'm speaking for Val whose business and
home is sandwiched between your property
and hail Taffy so she is directly
affected by all this vibration comes
through her building from whatever
source for example the air extraction
equipment and so forth the walls are
painfully thin I don't know if you
realize that a bedroom's upstairs she
hears everything that goes on she also
has a beautiful garden at the back which
she enjoys obviously and if there are
going to be people outside smoking and
drinking then uh I know the license
won't cover it but nevertheless there's
a potential to disruption that what
puzzles me is that this is Harold
Village and you're talking apparently in
a mistake that you submitted the hours
that were suitable for Manchester which
is two very different areas that's why
they've amended them they've amended
them the hours
accepts the evening situation
what seems strange is why you would want
to open at 10 o'clock in the morning
when most of people the businesses
similar to yours such as chibo and
piccolino open either a midday or 11
o'clock in the morning so I can't see
the necessity for 10 am quite frankly
well if that's the question you should
have asked it when the applicant when we
were questioning the applicant but I
mean I will allow it if you want to
answer that one
I thought it would be part of the
presentation
well it's a question you're asking him
why is it why he wants to open at 10 A.M
in the morning no I'm asking you the
licensing committee to
that they open later in the morning and
the other thing is that this is for 365
days in the year
so that you don't get any respite at all
whereas a lot of the businesses in hell
close on a Monday and one or two on a
Tuesday as well so if you think about
living with that
all year round I'm asking
would it not be possible to put
conditions in that they open an hour
later and they don't open every single
day of the year so you're objecting to
the 10 o'clock start in effect yes so
what what do you think is a reasonable
well bearing in mind that Cibo seems to
be just about the most successful
restaurant in hail and piccolino have
been there a long time both of them open
at 12 o'clock lunch time
so that would be that one and the other
one is with
the majority can I can I just ask if we
have access to the licenses to them to
places you just mentioned because I'm
sure the license is from 10 o'clock and
that's what I want to clarify having the
license doesn't necessarily mean that
you're going to be used as it's as it
stands from 10 o'clock to midnight or
half 11. as I said or as I try to
explain it's something that is going to
be there but we're not going to be used
uh first of all no we're not going to
open every day of the year
yeah
we don't know yet we will have to do a a
three months period to see what days are
you know worth keeping it open
worthwhile the the value of the cost of
the staff and everything
but yeah we're looking at closing
between one or two days a week we don't
know which days that's what we need the
license to be there for every day and
therefore until we know that until we
test the waters and see what days are
quieter we will close them days maybe it
could be one day maybe it could be two
maybe it could be none I'm not saying I
will I will close but this is how it
usually works with businesses and I
guarantee you that picolino and chivo
they have license from 10 o'clock now if
they choose to open at 12 is there
called we don't we usually open at 12
anyway as well
um so but there are days that we need to
open early because we're closing earlier
as well it will be days that might be
not may not be trading for lunch at all
just evenings so it could be a
variational a lot of things so yes I
understand that you look at the
licensing application you think oh this
guy's gonna be there from 10 o'clock to
11 every day of my life
yeah
I don't think so I don't think so
since we're not licensed
that that could be an aspect we have to
take it on the hours that you've applied
for
and that's why
um this point is being raised that it's
every day of the year and quoting a
couple of restaurants to you that open
later in the morning can I can I help
you to this extent the legal advice that
I would give to the committee if I'm
asked to
will be that the committee has to
consider the application as it is put in
I am not aware of any license premises
conditions where it has been within a
licensing committee's remit to impose
conditions that license premises must
close on certain days of the week it's
not simply something that is within the
licensing committee's remit to do that
further there are licensed premises and
I've got a schedule before the Spice
Lounge for example has a license from 10
o'clock so in the morning so does the
railway in so does the cinnamon on
Mondays to Saturdays
um
so does the Jake Jeju Indian Street Food
the attica's kitchen bar inhale the elk
has Licensing hours that begin at nine
o'clock in the morning the garden at 154
Ashley Road has Licensing hours that
start at eight o'clock in the morning
cook Haley Ashley Road starts at 9 30 in
the morning the the cigarette cigarette
173 at Ashley Road does have a license
that starts at 12. Victor's has
Licensing hours that start at eight in
the morning
Ricardo's at 12 o'clock uh in the
morning
and I think that's probably the last one
no the west gate bar has Licensing hours
of 12. the goo shop 199 Ashley Road
starts at 10. so there are a variety of
different Licensing hours uh there and I
suspect that you'd find that not all the
premises open all of the time with very
great respect a lot of those premises
have closed in the last few years
however it still doesn't change the fact
that
um
we would ask that they didn't open at 10
o'clock in the morning
just to give a bit of respite because if
you're saying that you've got to issue a
nice license for the whole year
could I just actually respite from what
at 10 o'clock in the morning
all of which are covered as I understand
it by the licensing you know disturbance
yeah but it's not likely to be at that
time in the morning it's more likely to
be 10 o'clock at night
or I mean it's all relative
but as it's been pointed out a lot of
establishments arises from eight nine
o'clock but they don't choose to use
those hours
and they might not choose to open at 10
o'clock that's that's their right if
they wanted to but they don't have to
and a lot of a lot of establishments
dues not to because it wouldn't be
economically viable
true I can understand that but on the
other hand I think residents do have
um
some consideration given to them from
the noise aspect well if it's a problem
if we see it's a problem we can't at
this point see it's a problem at 10
o'clock in the morning the the late hour
we can see which has already been
reduced
to 11 half 11.
but we you know I can't I I can't get my
head around what the problem would be at
10 o'clock in the morning if I'm sorry
if that's nitpicking but on the other
hand to have
activities such as this with music
going on every day of the year
it's right not intrusive for residents
as it's been stated uh by the solicitor
we can't impose conditions that they can
only open certain days of the year but
as the applicant said they're not
they're not going to be opened every
every day
you know they they were going to I
suppose look at which of the best days
to open so their business yes I can
understand that the other thing is that
while you
were talking about the Taverna I mean we
weren't happy with the opening hours
that they've been given
the work story The the closing times if
you like
a fish establishment oh I'm sorry well
we can only we can only consider what's
in front of us other applications or or
even
uh you know the planning for this
establishment or the licensing for other
establishments we can only consider the
licensing for this establishment so
anyway I'd like to move on if that
concludes you well thank you very much
it has been useful can I ask if uh if
the applicant has any questions for
the members of the public
yes I know you asked some questions I
asked the questions before about the
rest of the licenses thank you do you
have any questions
members of the public
not no no
okay
all right in in that case I'm going to
ask both parties just to well as as
briefly as they can I suppose summarize
the the case
starting with the representators would
you just like to conclude with a summary
of of what your what Your Case is please
um
I would like you to consider when you're
making your decision on this application
these factors want the location
is in a residential area at the very end
of the village and I did it books and is
next to all Residential Properties on
all sides
to the size of the property in
comparison to other commercial premises
in that line
three
the elevated height projects the noise
when the doors are open straight over
the garden walls into the rear of the
properties on Spring Road and to the
rear Gardens and properties of Ashley
Grove
for the noise that will be created by
other premises which are in close
proximity
hail Tavern on the Railroad pub at
particular times
five
uh well okay sorry
the terrorists
if the doors are open sorry if the use
of the Terrace obviously I was going to
say with the use of the Terrace the
doors are open and that means the noise
is emitted I apologize ignore that one
six
um
we know that for 20 years this property
operated and caused absolutely no noise
nuisance to anybody because the rear
doors were kept closed as were the
windows at all times
um finally this is a conservation area
and we are in severe danger of losing a
wonderful suburb to living a family
suburb with wonderful houses and we we
feel extremely lucky to live in that
area but unfortunately we feel that if
if this sort of application is granted
the whole character there is changing
which is a tragedy
okay thank you very much and then ask
the applicant just to summarize the
application please yeah so
we don't think we ask him for anything
that he already exists around us and
that already had existed in the same
premises and I think that area of the
Village
um as most of the people we've been
talking to it's a bit
left to the hands of God and I think by
implementing
um and bringing
a brand like ours
will give the value for uh what what
they deserved at the first place we
don't think we're going to have any
problems I
I can only say that now but in few years
time we would have a conversation yeah
you would say you know what yeah thank
God it was you and not nobody else
because you've been very very respectful
to us you've been very understandable
and that's what I would like to be the
outcome of these in a couple of years
and if you had to choose again you could
choose me to be your restaurant neighbor
but I don't think he's unfair what we're
asking for is not unfair given the rest
of the licenses that have been given and
approved in the recent days
and with the ones also that they already
existed there
[Music]
okay thank you everybody for your
submissions
um the committee and officers are now
legal official now retired to consider
the the application and we'll come back
in a few minutes with a decision
so thank you for your contribution so
far thank you